こんにちはーネットでの悪口は許しませんユーチューバー警察弾み社長です神の色が
議員になりました
よろしくで入ってきて皆さんに先生どのように扱っていますでしょうか
私 youtube はじめ社長はですねばね等 sns そういう強さを人一倍理解
している自信がありますだけでパラ youtube で顔だして動画を出していると
エヴァコーナーがいる
言われたり脂肪中傷がかなりあるんですよ
俗に我々は杏と呼んでいるものなんですけどもまぁアンスっていうのは非常にですね
ネットマナーとしては最低が向上している人たちがいいますねさせてに私たちの
youtube 長い間行ってきてもう誰に何を言われてもイラっと面白いですので何
とも思わないんですよ
無敵のメンタルを手に入れたわけですから無敵の女んだろうって
に入れたわけなんですけれども結局そのアンチとか誹謗中傷って声自体はマジでや良く
ないなと思ってるんでちょっとでもそれを食い止めるために今日はアンチと戦ってみ
たいと思います戦うってどっちかというとですね戦闘を繰り広げながら最終的に簡単に
ですねネットで悪口を言う人にガツンとダメだぞということを教えようと思いますでも
行こう
だよ
[音楽]
大じゃあやっていきたいとおもいますちょっと名前とかは流石に各させていただくん
ですけども
この人最近あの僕に結構非常に良くない悪口とかを送ってくる方がいいまして
がたくの虫を叩きのめしはしないんですけどよくないんですよ
それに最近送られたやつだとあの僕がやばい新幹線でてたら青森通過せた北海と寸前
まで来てボトル
ガチでヤバイぺーぺー取材した山田まで帰ってくんだと
[音楽]
お前誰だ
ああああこっちゃいないんですけどまぁこんなの突然知らない人から言われるとさせ
ないんだでもいい気はしないと思うんですよねそしてご覧くださいこちら
後輩の大腸検査の結果の紙でメールをつくってみましたよかったらやってみてね
死ねっ
yeah
誰だお姉コレではまずでよくないですが twitter の音利用規約にもよくない
です湿っても撮影4号ですからね
なぜかおまめサンシローさんにフォローされていますこれはさせよくないと思うので私
がしっかりと更生させていただきますと言います dm でしっかりとお話しましょう
まぁちょっといけないあの僕も言われるようなこと言われてるんでちょっとそんなした
西谷いい
ことでありません湿原は普段だったらあの2までまず靴は良くないんですよって言うん
ですけど
死ねって言われてあの僕別で起こってないんですけどやっぱ
怒ってる風にしたほうがいいと思うんでちょっと怒りめていきますしねは本当によく
ないので
おい
いつまたやつやばい緊張セクター xs ためのプラダメって言わないといけないので
暴言良くないんですがよ敬語を使いつつもちょっと慣れてる感じのちょっと所政府の
言葉つがいで攻めてみようと思いますちょっとが起こっているてー何で頭に血が上り
まくっててちょっと覚えてる感じに行くんですよ
もうなんか裏手に出るのは下手に言ってるのがわかんない感じですね
池に多いで始まり高原良くないでしょばよ黙れ編知らないと言われたら嫌やろうっと
まあまあ守りましょうよ
最後はちょっと優しく言ってみましたまあすごく思ってねー
pot ある程度ちょっと行かせていただきますでは返信を待ちましょう
快適なお待たせいたしました2時間くらいが経過してようやくあの帰ってきました
いや僕は大丈夫ですあなたの継母を使いましょう
わーっないといけちょっと何が大丈夫なのかよくわからないんですけども
本人的には大丈夫やすいですだめですネットマナーは誰しもが守らなければいけない
こと
ぜひ皆さん守りましょう越前とっさにきちゃってついついテンションがかぶってしまっ
てあのブタさんのスタートを返してしまいました
いや大丈夫じゃないです阿部嫌だいす
ためをになってしまいますつづく賞を贈りましょう癒しには程よくないんだよの
ちゃんとこういうの綾部ナイフ投げちゃいます4群よくないですよやっぱりこういう
アンチというかネットのマナーがなってない方って僕は大丈夫って思ってるとかでも
よくないと思うんですよねっと待ってるのは誰妻が大事なことでしたかそれにあの暴言
吐いくってことをダメっていうのはからていただきたいのでちょっと
私に謝ってもらえればうれしいなと思っておりますしばらく待ってみましょう
[音楽]
吐き
帰宅時だけだっ
を
謝ってくれたやっぱり根はいい人なのかなぁちょっと口うるさい先生みたいな感じて
おきます後ソナンデシネと戦ってきたいんですよ
偉大だと走って無邪武舎して送るようでしたら本当にやってはいけないと私を持って
おりますはいと夕食帰ってきました
た攻めの顔を受けてしまったら誰
最近動画が面白くないんで動画頑張ってください
[音楽]
ちょっといつもだったらここで落ち着くんですけども今日はちょっとだけ攻めてみまし
たーこっちもなぁ
時間やなぁ動画とってんだあーっアクっ子を見たら怖い感じで面白いかって
しニョッキをつけろみたいな感じでちょっと強い行ってみましょう
かつや好きだったんですけどねありがとうございます知覧はそんな
今は好きちゃう t they レイヤー
前もあんたのブースきつ駅ライナー
暴言吐く人は嫌い
アブだねちょっと今ならアメラグは今日は誰かに来てるですからね
ちょっと嬉しい待ってしまったなんてないそうかな神秘を言って好きになっちゃうん
ですよね
当初なって書くかないやーここもちょっとありがとう p タイトなんですけど知らん
はちょっと強めに送っていきましょう
とりあえず反省しなさいすねとか言うな人に気づく野郎
場合は傷ついたって
えっを飲みたいだ
人は傷ついて強くなるよ
だめだ強くなれないとボルには y は大丈夫だけどそして追い打ちの画像を投げて
いきます今度から楽しくついたを束ねない人を傷付けないようになったこれが一番なん
ですよね9 youtube twitter も何書いてもいいと思うんですけど人
に迷惑をかけずに生きることは無理だと思うのでできる限りそういうボーディンとが
規模2社はなるべくいろんな方がいいなって感じなの分かってくれれば
いいなって思ってますね
おおーー
パズ目を守る福祉てよあ
予報やイライラしてきたんダメだなぁも折らないならやレナーも本当にこの一言に
尽きると思います
をな部下
やバクッと本音からのアンツだなぁちょっと真面目で楽しませ常に剣客的な口調でき
ます
セブ駅で誰か立っていきますよお前何歳もう完全にはこれでとっしゅ歌った強いんです
ねこれでと性だったらまずでやばいですけどめっかっギャラいいますからねもう
ななっ
質問に答えろや
朝どんどん扱って黙った
始めたぞかこんなふう贈るなら絶対思ってないと思うんですけど a
矢部と入り込んでしまったさすがにかわいそうなことを一つ入って前戯に聞いてみます
自分で教えてください
薄したやったらなんかいう夜になっても実施しただろうと越部たのと関係ないんですよ
ねこの手の話題はもうすねとかそういうことを言った図面ですそいつは悪いですから
まだまだん
大きさきた結果ようやく帰ってきたような
さあ
地代の続きをすよん
仕事したらあっ仕事せダウン
恋妻ず舐め腐ってやがるなあと1回いつも通りの鍵は伝えに戻して気が緩んだところに
ズバーっと入れます
[音楽]
仕事で忙しいのかなぁ
だったら本当に申し訳ないと思いますだが暴言は許しませんとってのこの可愛い感じで
やってちょっとこのなぁはじめいい奴だなぁと思った瞬間
パーシーつ一発入れていくことを思います入ってゆけで帰ってきました
8すまん20
に開け52
してんじゃんもう一なお良い子ちょっと今イライラさせるという作戦なのかもしれませ
ん
私はそんな手には乗りません
乗りませんそうなのか俺は20億円でいい奴かは分からんが暴言吐いたり死ぬとか言う
なら
twitter やめなさいそしてはおりです
缶詰のいいやつやろなんか代行してくれる孟母言わないか
ちょっとやっぱ歳いってことはわかったんでちょっと2部の言葉で構築近い作ってさせ
ていますや
教えなくてもう酷い言葉で誰かを傷つけないでくれ
22歳でしょう22歳がツイッター列車じゃない人に[ __ ]とか言ってるのマジで引くわ
もうそんなに
twitter で[ __ ]とか言ってるの攻めた中学生までだと思ってたらどうするかな
数店に飯食いに来て余波
バカにするのもほどほどにしろよ
今度笑い事じゃないぞまで彼と僕は心を通ずることができないのかもしれないこちらは
来てちょっともうダメですこれ以上話としても多分通じないですの食べる
曝気とはっはっは
ありがとやとりあえずの多分こいつな[ __ ]とか黙れということを悪いっていう時間が
全くないんでこれじゃ多分その話をしても一切通じない気がしました
ロックさせていただきましたァンツって結構いたし今までも理不尽なことで怒ってくる
なんか変なもういいか出てる人たちもたくさんいたんですけど全く触れずにスルー
できるしも全然気にもなんないんですけども
なので客にあえて
今回あのバトルしてみました
話見た感じでやばいですね22歳になってツイッターで知らない人に死ねって送ってる
のがビックリなやっぱ net バナーがね全然なんてないです
今の人たちは
僕も含めかもしれないですけど偉そうなことを言える人間じゃないんですけどまぁ
少なくともですねホットバンド暴力っていう言葉があるくらい
やっぱ暴言とかで非常に人を苦しめる可能性があるのでちょっとこいつにもちょっと何
とかしてあげたかったんですけど本当にあのネットの使い方というか sns の使い
方は気をつけたほうがいいかなと思います萌え
今会話したアンチもいた淀の会を3回
してみたちとよく考えてみてください一応ユーチューバー警察はじめしゃちょーでした
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ